also leute ich wieder aufgewacht und
haben nichts ahnt hugo geöffnet einfach
mal reingeschaut dann gehe ich in den
shop und ich sehe das hier
ich habe 14 1580 pokemons ich habe keine
ahnung warum also ich hab mir vorgestern
100 points gekauft und wie ihr seht
14.500 sind die variante die 100 euro
kostet und ich habe wirklich überhaupt
keinen plan wie oder warum
ja ich habe gerade eben das gerät direkt
mal passwort geändert vom vom app store
aber ich verstehe das nicht also ich hab
gerade mal kurz nach gelesen man kann
anscheinend käufe irgendwie rückgängig
machen und ich weiß nicht was abgeht
immer irgendwie wäre es cool die ganzen
publikums zu haben ich dachte irgendwie
dass so eine keule seite oder somit
vielleicht geschenkt hat
aber es hat einfach 100 euro gekostet
pokals für 100 euro ohne dass ich
irgendwas gedrückt habe oder so was zur
hölle ich meine kirche san ist kein fake
also ich hab ja nicht irgendwie material
eingeblendet oder so wenn dann ich habe
phuket 14 14 1580 points ich hab die
nicht bewusst gekauft oder so kommt wenn
ihn jemand schaut das hier ist meine
itunes kauf übersicht 14.500 poker
müssen an allen ticket kauf einer zu neu
freut sich über 99 und weil davor ist
sogar sind sogar die 100 ich tatsächlich
getraut habe aber einfach für 1 euro pro
kons also wirklich ich war einfach nur
aufgewacht ich bin aber ich bin darauf
gehört nicht dafür
ich denke mal gucken und jetzt das ding
einfach automatisch weißen wie das
funktioniert ich glaube man hat ja die
apple id wenn man die eingegeben hat um
einkauf zu tätigen
hat man einen kurzen zeiten wo man sie
nicht eingeben muss und dann habe ich
wahrscheinlich irgendwie 100 kauft das
handy in meine hosentasche gesteckt und
dann aus versehen für 100 euro welche
getroffen käßmann ich hier bei den 100
euro pro kommission fand die auf ein
problem melden klicken problem auswählen
ich habe diesen versehentlich gekauft
senden
dieser kauf kann nicht erstattet werden
das wird wieder herum verarschen
warum nicht erhalt ihrer rechnung güte
betrag gekauft wurde studiert er
betreibt mit ihrer zahlungsmethode
zurückerstattet die sollten diese
werkstatt innerhalb der nächsten fünf
bis zehn geschäftstage erhalten
gespannt die fans gespannt was mit dem
poker points passiert ich mein ich habe
jetzt in meinem account werden die dann
abgezogen oder was passiert damit
verstehst und weil wirklich ich habe die
ich schwöre auf alles dass ich die nicht
gekauft habe also ich war in der app und
ich habe mir für 100 punkten münzen
welche gekauft und habe sie mir das
messer in die tasche gesteckt haben
dann hat vielleicht auch taschen kauf
autorisiert den verkehrsteiler 514 1580
profilfach aber ich glaube nicht dass es
hier ausgeben kann weil ich mal jetzt im
moment wollen die das geld wieder
einziehen
dann müssten wir müssen das geld er
wieder zurückgeben und ich blicke nicht
wirklich durch vorleute gehe ich erst
mal frühstücken
ich hoffe das klappt alles wir stellten
eine ring ist das der fall da er eine
rückerstattung des kaufpreises erfolgt
weiter ist hier nichts zu tun mit in der
inneren korb auch im band macht
schon sagte die inhalte werden künstler
vom pd-f entfernt
so leute ich dachte mir ich updater euch
jetzt nochmal mit dem ganzen wir haben
jetzt fünf tage später und ich kann euch
so viel sagen ich habe mein geld wieder
bekommen also das ganze wurde nicht
irgendwie abgelehnt oder so das
überraschende ist wenn ihr mal schaut
ich habe immer noch meine 14.500 focal
points und das überrascht mich halt
total weil ich mein ich habe zwar das
geld zurück bekommen aber die pokemons
habe ich immer noch aber ich denke mal
ist es immer noch besser wenn ich die
ein bisschen unberührt lasse weil keine
ahnung nicht dass ich dann irgendwie
vertragsbrüchig werde oder sonst was
ich habe mich jetzt nicht rechtlich gras
mit auseinandergesetzt oder so aber es
wäre irgendwie einfach unfair wenn ich
jetzt das ganze zeug behalte obwohl aber
es wäre auch unfair wenn ich jetzt das
ganze zeug behalte ohne dass ich es
irgendwie wirklich bezahlt habe ich
meine es gibt bestimmt genug leute die
sich pokémon sowie zum geburtstag
gewünscht haben oder geld dafür gespart
haben oder so ich würde sie dann quasi
kostenlos kriegen also ich warte erstmal
ein bisschen ab was passiert ansonsten
denke ich mal
vielleicht halten mit jetzt ein paar von
euch verrückt aber ich denke mal
vielleicht melde ich mich wirklich noch
mal einen tick oder beim apple store
oder sonntag
ihr habt etwas vergessen weil wenn man
ehrlich ist ich brauche die pokemons
eigentlich gar nicht mannschaft ich mal
meine meine items an also tränke und
sowas habe ich alles zu genüge welle
habe ich zur genüge lockte lohnen sich
eh nicht mehr aus butter ok werden ganz
lustig aber meisten sachen kriegst du
sowieso
ich mein ich bin zwar erst level 25 weil
viele sind ja was heißt ich level 30
oder so ich verstehe auch nicht wie
manche leute so schnell so hoch gekommen
sind also ich bin level 25 aber ich
level halten ich mich entwickeln nicht
mehr besonders viel pokémon oder so wenn
ihr euch mal ein pokédex anschaut ich
habe 128 pokémon gefangen und 129
gesehen also
gut das einzige ist dass dieser floh rum
wenn euch das mal durch stadt ich habe
jetzt mittlerweile schon echt ein paar
ganz neues pokémon da braucht sollte ich
mir die lok module oder sonst was sollte
so spezielle pokémon brauchst dass du am
besten irgendwelche anderen
möglichkeiten wie ist und man die dinger
zu kommen bleibt was habe ich jetzt
gefangen aber leider sehr traurig dass
hier ist das laut fas das letztes
gefangen habe also eine sehr traurige
existenz hat zwar top attacken aber
leider nur wp 306 ich wollte ich gleich
einmal mein aktuelles pokémon team
zeigen aber bevor ich das tool noch ein
paar infos für euch ihr seht schon wie
hier oben gerade werbe video auftaucht
und zwar habe ich euch ein bisschen was
zu erzählen
die wohnt nämlich in der echt coole
sache angeschrieben und zwar werde ich
diese sonntag den 25
september in berlin sein dort bin ich
dann mit hd wenig kraft öfter banks und
mir und zwar weil wir von makros
eingeladen wurden nach kurs ist netflix
serie die sich um die kriminellen
machenschaften von pablo escobar dreht
und da ist jetzt gerade die zweite
staffel gelohnt und wir sind ja zu
diesem krassen live event in berlin
eingeladen worden das sich um diese
zweite staffel dreht in der zweiten
staffel geht es nämlich um die jagd auf
pablo escobar und wir werden auch pablo
escobar jagen und zwar bei diesem live
event wie ich bereits gesagt habe wird
das ganze am sonntag live übertragen und
zwar von 18 bis 20 uhr auf der
facebook-seite von netflix und diversen
live streams kann nur soviel sagen ich
selbst feiere nach groß wirklich total
und ich bin mir sicher dass sich die
jungs von netflix als krasses überlegt
haben also es lohnt sich bestimmt
reinzuschauen bevor ich euch jetzt aber
noch mein aktuelles pokémon team zeige
hier noch eine minute trailer pablo
escobars mayday parade
mary der brings motor
die svp
das gerät gibt orientieren
inter kam ihre muslime und balkon
paulis control ist
deshalb kostüm des landes
jung
unters publikum
so leute das war der trailer also alles
wann und wie ihr dabei zuschauen können
finde ich nochmal unten in der
beschreibung und ja jetzt zu meinen
pokémon zu meinem aktuellen team auf der
nummer eins ist nach wie vor mein dragan
was ich ja mehr oder weniger in einem
video gefangen habe das ist jetzt
mittlerweile auf 2.575 gutes dingen
darauf folgt mein ak nie das habe ich
auch schon etwas länger
jack warner nummer eins aktuelle nummer
zwei radios habe ich jetzt relativ neu
sieht man auch daran dass ich das kann
ich ja gerade mal ein bisschen leveln
weiß ich ja sagen wollte sieht man auch
daran dass ich nicht komplett hoch
gelevelt habe ja ich kann es jetzt
gerade mal ein bisschen leveln so 1873
ein relativ hohes potential muss halt
auch ganz gut und janna quaner 2 blamage
lahm muss pixi jetzt gehe ich mal raus
kwaku habe ich noch nie zu ross habe ich
neu und ja ihr seht den habe ich auch
heute bekommt den kollegen mega gute
muss also 1 15er starken 120er
überstrahlt ich habe vor allem eine
pokémon go zeit darin investiert dass
sich halt irgendwie ja wie soll ich
sagen exotisches thema weil andere sind
zwar höher als ich aber haben halt nicht
so viele unterschiedliche pokémon
gefangen naja alles in einem hoffe ich
mal das video hat euch heute gefallen
und euch hängt pokémon gar nicht
allzusehr zum hals heraus ich musste
euch heute einfach diese story erzählen
die sich um diese ganze 100 euro pokern
geschichte erstreckt hat ja das war's
dann von heute macht es gut und bis zum
nächsten mal